julian edelman who has moved forward
from football retiring earlier this year
kind of out of the blue but but it was
known apparently that this guy was done
here he is with michael irvin talking
about his decision to walk away from the
game
my knees breaking down i'm not gonna sit
here and i got everything i want you
know i got three rings
played in a magical dynasty
uh with an unbelievable franchise coach
best quarterback of all time like
yo
i'm not a greedy guy
i played to win i played to compete
i don't need anything else to prove you
know so like i'm good with what i did i
left it all on the field
and you know that that's why i had to
shut her down i'm not going to sit out
there and
look like some old dude and those an old
bike neat grace and your ankle braces
and you know the old guy i don't want to
look like that man can't do that
i didn't know better i'd say he's
throwing shade at tom brady tom brady's
the old guy who's out there with all the
contraptions on his body tom brady's the
greedy guy that had to have more and got
out of new england i don't want to read
too much into it but i also don't want
to ignore what's sitting right in front
of our face you look at what he said tom
brady is the picture that emerges from
it
well you know what i'm disappointed with
is they haven't put up the conspiracy
mic yet right so we always that's not
much of a conspiracy no stop they do hey
they don't need any help
please don't include that's a good point
go ahead
yeah mike you're right
he doesn't want to be that guy i guess
who wins more championships and has all
the contraption on him because that's
certainly what tom brady has done and he
had off season knee surgery as we know
so that guy just keeps going and going
and going he's certainly not a one team
guy
edelman said his knees breaking down and
and that's that's the thing it gets to a
point where it's bone on bone the knee
just doesn't work right and and you just
have to move on but but
and i haven't listened to the whole
podcast or
really anything more than the clip we
just played but
you got rob gronkowski who has on
multiple occasions now
said
he'll he'll be back
he'll be back you know and part of it is
gronk's been on that journey before
gronk knows what it's like to say i've
had enough i'm done
it's over i'm moving on with my life and
then here comes a football season and oh
man my life doesn't feel the it's not
this something's not right here
something something's missing
something i've been doing this since i
was a little boy i can't let this go on
without me now he ended up sitting out
an entire season and if tom brady never
goes to tampa bay maybe gronkowski never
comes back
but
you've already got your buddies in tampa
they've already got a super bowl ready
team
if if he can get that need to where
it allows him
with whatever contraptions he would
choose to put on it to go out there and
play
even at a fraction of what he played at
with new england
and he's got and this is the other key
too
hard is brady gonna work on him and work
on him and work on him and work on him
if he really thinks he's gonna make a
difference and maybe brady just realizes
yeah but forget it you know i'm fine
with the guys i have now but that's the
one thing we don't know is whether or
not brady is aggressively going to work
on him behind the scenes brady made some
jokes a few weeks ago during the nfl's
draft-a-thon toward edelman
saying that you know he he he's just
afraid to say that he's going to tampa
because he doesn't want to make bill mad
but uh
i'm still not ready to slam the door on
it he can say whatever he wants because
even he doesn't know how he's going to
feel when august september and october
roll around
yeah i think what we know mike is he's
not capable of playing a 17 game season
i i think that much is clear okay so you
know he didn't play that many games last
year the knees are breaking down we get
that so he's not going to play a 17 game
season but i'm not going to be at all
surprised if the buccaneers have an
injury late in the year and they pick up
the phone and call julian edelman and
say hey bud come back we really need you
here uh just a few games that's all
you're playing and then we need you for
the postseason where you've really
shined anyway in the 19 games you've
been you've played in the postseason
you've been one of the greatest
postseason players in nfl history so
come back and and do it for us and have
a chance to win another one and i can
definitely see him doing that we saw
that with michonne lynch now i know
marshawn played for more than one team
so it wasn't like he was just going you
know going back to the one team he went
to which holy uh julian would be moving
on to a new team that he's never played
with but marchand did it right he played
week 17 and then he came back and he
played in the postseason for the
seahawks uh when they needed him so i
could see julian edelman doing something
similar with the buccaneers if they have
an injury late in the year they need a
very productive receiver okay this is
the guy we're gonna call he knows tom
brady tom pick up the phone and call him
and he'll be back so i'm not ready to
shut that door either mike i can see
julian edelman coming back for a handful
of games at the end of the year to try
to win another championship
uh first of all as pete pointed out it
sounds like we need a shireen
a conspiracy shireen graphic i knew i
was gonna screw that up because
that's that's exactly what you were
trying to bait me into saying earlier
but it's not a big conspiracy theory
it's obvious and here's the other thing
too and i know this is going to make
some patriots fans upset i've said it
before and it's made them upset and i
would i would never say this about
somebody who didn't serve a four-game
ped suspension and his excuse for it was
i don't know what happened well we do
and everyone else does you took
performance-enhancing substances to
allow yourself to be able to recover
from an injury or get some edge so you
get back on the field
i say that because i've already done the
research i've already asked the
questions he's completely beyond the
nfl's jurisdiction now he can take
whatever he wants to take to get that
need to respond in whatever way whatever
experimental procedures whatever
medication whatever may be on the nfl's
list of substances you can you go crazy
now to get that need to respond do
whatever you have to do to get that knee
back because you're off the grid as far
as the nfl's ped testing is concerned
and then you get it healed up and you
can come back and and that's really not
that controversial of a position it is
going to upset some folks in new england
who despite the fact that he was popped
for peds refused to acknowledge that
anyone would do anything like that to
get their bodies right to play nfl
football
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports